Okay, let's dig into these new DNC debate
requirements.
The Democratic Party has put in place some
new and stricter requirements to make the
third and fourth officially DNC sanctioned
primary debates, which are scheduled to take
place in a, we'll put it up on the screen
in a second, but I believe it's a September
and October is when debates three and four
will take place.
And there's a lot to talk about here and I
want to sort of do this justice and really
go through it piece by piece and think it
through because a lot of the reactions I've
seen online to these requirements are not
making a lot of sense.
So first let's zoom out a little bit.
Why do we have requirements?
Why do we have minimum standards that need
to be met to participate in debates?
Well, if you have no standards at all, you
can end up with dozens, 50 I mean you've got
to have some, you know, does anyone who announces
a candidacy get to participate in DNC sanctioned
debates?
There's anybody who's on the ballot in even
one state get to participate.
It's chaos if you have no minimum requirements
whatsoever.
But on the other side of this, we know 2016
being a prime example that the DNC has ways
of influencing the Democratic primary that
can be anti progressive anti insurgent candidate
and basically pro status quo, pro establishment
candidate.
And so what we don't want to have our requirements
that are so strict that they preempted the
possibility of having serious insurgent progressive
candidates and challengers for the 2028 Democratic
primary.
So the first debates are in late June and
late July.
We're very close.
I mean we're a month from the first debate
and the requirements for those first two debates,
which are going to be split into a and B,
uh, because the field is still so large.
The requirement for those first two debates,
which will be debate one a and one B and debate
two a and two B.
We've known about these for a while.
65,000 individual donors and you need to be
polling 1% in three qualified polls closer
to the date of the debate.
So the pope will look at the polls now have
to figure out who would be in as of today.
Uh, but what's going to matter is how the
candidates are doing closer to the debates
in mid to late June.
So we'll put up on the screen for you.
Also the requirements for the following debates.
So first two debates, 65 k donors and 1% in
three qualified polls.
The DNC has now added stricter requirements
for debates three and four and debates three
and four.
The requirements double the donor number two,
130,000 donors.
And they also double the polling requirement
to 2% instead of 1% and that needs to be in
for rather than just three poles.
So the criticisms immediately from some people
have been, this is going to destroy the field.
This is unfair to smaller candidates.
This is a establishment DNC move.
This is potentially going to alienate donors
to those, uh, uh, lower ranked candidates
because they will say, well, why am I even
going to bother if these new, even higher
requirements are going to keep them out of
the third and forth debate anyway, we want
the field to stay bigger for a longer period
of time.
I think we have to break this down into two
parts, the donor requirement and the polling
requirement.
Okay.
Let's first talk about the 2% polling requirement.
Um, the DNC, uh, the convention is in, it's
in the summer.
I don't know if it's scheduled for June, July,
or August, but it's in summer of 2020.
If you don't have 2% by the third debate in
September, I believe it is completely reasonable
to say you can't continue being in the officially
sanctioned DNC debates.
If you can't get to 2% after two national
debates and six or seven months of campaigning
for most of these candidates, you don't have
a shot and you are becoming a distraction
period and you're taking time away from the
candidates who are in this thing, having time
to better flesh out and talk about their ideas.
I have no problem whatsoever with a 2% polling
requirement for the third and fourth debates.
The question mark for me is a 130,000 donors.
Okay.
Bill share pointed out on Twitter that back
in 2008, John Edwards had like 20,000 donors
or something like that at a relatively advanced
point in the campaign.
He was a serious candidate in terms of the
polling.
Um, but uh, he did not have a 130,000 donors.
So I think that it's really important to point
out that if we want to make a case that these
requirements are too strict, it's got to be
along the number of donors line.
I don't think there is any serious case to
be made that 2% by a September is too high
of a threshold.
Now, let's understand a little bit about,
uh, what the effect would be of the 1% and
2% polling requirements based on today's numbers.
Okay.
To be in the first debates, you need to pull
1%.
If we look at the current average polling,
remember what matters is how they pull right
before the debates.
Not right now, but let's imagine that we had
today's polling as the sort of way to decide
who gets into the debates.
You have Bennet Bullock, Hickenlooper, Seth
Moulton, Bill de Blasio, Delaney, Kirsten
Gillibrand, Marianne Williamson, Tim Ryan,
and Tulsi Gabard.
That's 10 candidates.
None of them are pulling 1% right now.
Okay?
There are uh, uh, or rather, I'm sorry, there
are 10 candidates who are polling 1% right
now and that's still a very solid number for
the first and second debate.
There is a broad range of opinion represented
among those 10 candidates.
So there would be a bunch of people who would
be out today if the requirement, we're 1%
but we would still have 10 people participating.
Very reasonable for this early in the game.
If the 2% requirement were put in place today,
you would still have Joe Biden, Bernie Sanders,
Elizabeth Warren, Kamala Harris, Pete Buddha,
judge Beto O'rourke and Cory booker.
That's seven candidates.
Okay.
If we have seven candidates by the third debate,
it is very reasonable.
And again, if you participate in to national
debates and you can't get 2% I don't believe
you deserve to keep taking up space on the
stage, you don't have a shot.
So the only debate for me is about the individual
donor number.
I get that donations are a way to prove your
viability, but 130,000 donors at 14 months
before the election, which is effectively
what September will be.
That might be too high.
Okay.
Can somebody pulling 1.8% in October end up
being the nominee by June?
I don't think they can.
Can someone with only 100,000 donors in octo
in October end up being the nominee in June?
I think they can.
I mean, it may be a long shot compared to
some of the other candidates, but that's where
the focus should be on getting these requirements
changed.
1% to be in debates, one to 2% to be in debates
three and four completely reasonable.
And I have not seen any serious argument,
uh, that that is too high of a requirement.
If you think I'm wrong, let me know.
We will have a pole on the David Pakman show
Instagram page about this
at the David Pakman show.
Check that out.
Follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
and while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at
David Dot. [inaudible] well,